what this Jason Lim can look for instant
an angel investment in the SAS space
well let's step back cuz I saw I spent
the last two years doing VC investments
and I I think I invested including
reserves forty or fifty million dollars
notionally right and forty million bucks
it's not that much I did ten I did I
sourced her led ten VC investments an
average check size was two and a half
million got it what's the reserves yeah
and it adds up to including a true NIOSH
or ventures anymore you're on finished
by twenty four months I learned a lot
I'd made some epic investments and going
you know tell you what's the most epic
they're all it's hard to which one has
the most objective returns now on paper
on paper yeah I think the the ones that
have the highest nav or markup are our
talk desk in guide spark okay so tell us
about this and those are both 10x
already Wow
I got it on the screen right now but
yeah you know I'll talk about I can talk
about a lot of things but let me step
back for a minute and tell you the uber
thing that I had the high level thing
that I learned and then we can dig into
the term the companies so I wasn't much
of an angel investment for and I did a
few companies that are doing really well
but I didn't have the structure or
process you did it was mostly people
just that I knew that I put some nickels
into it and that worked out but then
what I learned the biggest difference in
today's world between angel and VC is
sort of twofold one if you're uh if
you're a hot angel right if if it's you
if it's an Aaron Levie if it's a David
Sachs for different reasons you can get
into deals okay what's your average tech
sizes an angel historically 25k he used
to be a little higher a little higher
okay whatever it is if someone's raising
a half-million-dollar inch around or
even 250 or whatever it is there's room
if the founder wants you there's room as
a VC for if you're trying to write a
seven even a million dollar check two
million there's never room there's never
any age around there's there's never
room ever write ever and so uh you know
until about 2010 I would say and b2b
although this changed a lot and b2c much
earlier right but in in SAS as a VC you
could be a picker you could sit around
your office in Sand Hill until about
2010 or 2011 and to get a seven-figure
check every founder had to go around and
suck up to you and so you could be a
picker
right which you
early which a lot of enterprise be
season is it became a the founders or
had the power sure they do but I don't
do great vc it took longer it take
longer it took longer and I don't think
in SAS that was really true until maybe
2011 or 2010 and now you can pick so
early right and so my best investments
the talk desks the rainforest the Algol
II is the others we can talk about they
all picked me as a VC I didn't get to
pick them it may be picture why why do
you think they picked you they picked me
because their guess was out of what they
could figure it on the Internet's that I
might be able to help them scale revenue
more than the other guys cuz you were
blogging and talking about I've done it
as a founder yes Yuri there's two
reasons the second one is interesting
two one they probably thought I could
help them more than other VCS which I've
learned is certainly true most species
can't add any value really oh yeah but
second there's a second trend which you
saw early but came much later too to SAS
and B to B which is founders want a VC
that's a founder that's what we all want
as founders we don't want the financial
guy than the guy that looks us like a
piece of meat yeah we want the guy that
like yeah we don't and and and maybe and
maybe that's not even a good thing if we
had more time we could chat about that
founders aren't the best VC's it's the
financial managers that are the most
successful founders get passionate they
get irrational yeah they don't get the
reserves right they they they have other
issues but as founders the last thing we
want is to work for the man we don't
want to work for the man right so these
are the trends that have changed it in
so it took me a while to understand as a
as some of they've been a founder for so
many years then sort of an angel for
little Elmen huh thrown into VC I didn't
even know what had changed but then
founders started to come to me in the
early days interesting and I didn't know
what that meant and then I after about
six months I realized I'm done meeting
with any founder that hasn't picked me
ah very interest on so I don't you said
I'm not gonna chase deals I want the
people who understand I have some unique
value in the world and I went from doing
10 or 20 meetings a week to one and I
said I'm gonna do meet with one founder
a week and just what go deep I'm on a
pair I'm gonna pre-screen it I'm gonna
do my homework and I'm gonna look based
on what and I'll tell you what my best
criteria are next I'm gonna look for the
ones that I think are amazing and I'm
gonna I'm gonna do my homework ahead of
time and I'm gonna meet with someone
that's picked me maybe they shouldn't
have right they picked me and then I'm
gonna try to do the best and try meet
with 12 accord or 14 a quarter and try
and pick one a quarter mmm from that 12
and make the best investment I can okay
it's worked pretty well